you all probably know by now that when
channels like mine shows like mine talk
about stories like the one I'm about to
talk about we get demonetised
and penalized on YouTube and Facebook
but what has been captured on video over
the last 24 to 48 hours is two insane
and it's too important not to tell you
about it and to show it to you so let's
dig right into it first of all a New
York Police Department officers have
been caught on video
beating a cyclist with batons as he
tries to cross the street
the cyclist seems to be crossing his
bike while wearing a helmet at a
crosswalk mind you not even jaywalking
and multiple officers are just beating
the crap out of him and it looks like
they're beating the cyclist on the upper
leg eventually the cyclist is forced off
of his bike bike before the video ends
we don't know exactly what led up to it
but at this point in the video this is
not an individual that is resisting and
there are multiple officers beating him
with batons and this led to
congresswoman Alexandria Casio Cortes to
tweet quote horrifying you start with
the tiny possibility that two officers
may be walking over to de-escalate the
abusive one instead they join in beating
a man trying to get out of traffic this
isn't a problem of bad apples or
incidents this is an institutional and
systemic crisis and the reason I'm
picking this incident to talk about is
that congresswoman AOC s response
mirrors exactly what I've been talking
about all week when she says this isn't
a problem of bad apples or incidents
this is an institutional and systemic
crisis when I did my first commentary
about the protests and the civil unrest
that we're experiencing on the Monday
show that was the main point that I
tried to make the there were really two
points point one was anybody claiming
some grand unifying theory about this
this is all about capitalism this is all
about race this is all about police
brutality it's not so any grand unifying
theory that focuses on on one element is
destined to be to fall short but maybe
most
that the individual incidents may give
us a window into the systemic problems a
lens a suggestion but really we need to
be talking about the systemic aspects
that are plaguing our country and the
debate over good and bad police doesn't
actually address the systemic issues
that are at the heart of much of what is
going on in another video from North
Carolina police likewise were filmed in
this video they are destroying elements
of medical for lack of a better term a
sort of medical station that had some
medics and basic first-aid supplies and
a lot of bottled water you can see in
this video police standing above a ton
of destroyed and poured out bottled
water there in Asheville North Carolina
a report said that police hit some of
the medics with their shields and
knocked people to the ground and this is
again you know we can talk about
individuals but there's something
particularly nefarious in this instance
because of the principle called medical
neutrality so um we have norms that are
being ignored we've talked about you
don't go after press and we've seen
press attacked both by some protesters
and by police in different places over
the last week but now we're talking
about the principle of medical
neutrality in any conflict you do not go
after anybody who is providing medical
services you have a protest you have
police most protesters are peaceful most
police are good there's some scuffle you
do not pull the medical people into it
police may try to argue well you know if
the medical people weren't there the
protesters would be less brazen and
aggressive no at the international level
going after the the medical going after
medical is a violation of the Geneva
Convention these are of course domestic
protests we're talking about domestic
law enforcement the Geneva Conventions
don't apply but if this conflict instead
of being between protesters and looters
or police and protesters or police and
looters or whatever if this were a
conflict between two countries and the
Geneva Convention rules applied
either side destroying medical elements
would be a violation of the Geneva
Convention so we've got attacks on media
people from the press hit with rubber
bullets sprayed hit with shields almost
everything we've seen over the last
seven days the point of this segment is
not let's pick on police or particular
police any more than I pick on
individual protesters most protesters
are peaceful protesters are peaceful the
ones that aren't peaceful are really not
protesters they're doing other things
they're looters they're instigators
insiders whatever provocateurs police
are mostly doing the right thing and we
have shows of support and kneeling and
and singing and everything with police
from all over the country but this is
about the bigger picture we have a
horrible situation going on much of it
because of protests because of police
brutality and we are seeing everything
from cyclists beaten to a medical
station destroyed to a president saying
hey here's an idea for how to solve the
protests and unrest caused by police
brutality let's encourage more brutality
against protesters everything we are
seeing at a systemic level is the
opposite of what we need thankfully at
the individual level many police
departments have been great many
individual officers have been great
we've seen protesters bringing water to
police we've seen police joining
protesters and all of this stuff but
unless the systems are changed nothing
will change and so later on today a lot
of people on my streams this week and
via email have been saying David can you
explain how to deal with police
brutality and essentially none of it has
to do with the individual it is all
systemic changes and I'm going to
outline them for you a little bit later
on in the program